let's bring in Rick Fox he's a big timer
like this Rick have you ever sat in
first class and your kids sat in coach
yes it depends the age you know that
when they were honestly babies and kids
I've sat in i sat in coach with them for
sure but as my kids are 22 and 18
I've had them flying for his classes we
would have also had them flying coach
why what's different today
you know just the age of my kids and
whether or not they needed you know
supervise the dog look down but my kids
have also been unaccompanied minors for
you know four years so I've flown them
first classes unaccompanied minors as
well the coach sometimes it depends on
the availability last-minute flights so
lot that goes into it but yeah look I I
personally have done the coach up until
a certain age I can't remember what that
age was probably around 16 16 to 18 yeah
uh and then and then they're counting
out coaches coaches far enough for me at
times depending on you know how long the
flight is or you know whether or not I
you know I need the room in the space
physically when's the last time you went
middle seat coach oh I would like two
kids alongside of the other JetBlue
flight nah
yeah like okay big Lord to the Bahamas
all right now a couple of things to get
into it can you look at this as a
must-win situation for Golden State
tonight I know it is for Cleveland but
just perception wise pressure wise how
important is this for Golden State to
win this game today I would say uh more
pressure work more pressure wise the
perception they need to finish tonight
it could visit the doubt will creep in
whether they wanted to or not
I thought they they showed up the game 4
of 3 oh and had to be planning a little
bit of the celebration from the comments
if they're real and accurate and true
about wanting to celebrate on their
floor again I think tips a little bit to
the hand that they they felt they were
invincible against you know the calves
and in that case the calves put together
one of the best games of history so so
now can they duplicate that I don't know
if they can people kicked out the road
but the Warriors they definitely have
the Warriors attention again now and so
we're going to have to believe that the
Warriors will bring their best tonight
and if they're best at home against the
Cavs is not good enough
I think Game six brings a feel a huge
amount of pressure for sure for the
Warriors all right let's have a draft
here all right I'm going to take I'll
give you the first pick of all the
players that are playing in the finals
and you have to have them for the next
five years so you get you get the you go
first pick five years max contract you
go first
Cara Graham all right I'm going to take
him over LeBron huh yeah what if it's a
three years ah Kevin Durant he's Kevin
Durant I think I think I think the broad
has two more great years do you think
Kevin Durant's better than LeBron right
now
[Music]
no I think Kevin Durant has one egg one
one more player on his team man that was
a long pause Rick uh yeah yeah I I don't
think I don't think Kevin Durant is
better than abroad right now I think he
is on par for a notch that if the broad
is an a-plus-plus Kevin Durant is April
yeah I don't buy this the Kevin Durant's
on equal footing with LeBron there's no
way Kevin Durant could do what LeBron is
done it for Cleveland there's no way
Kevin Durant would add that team back
last year there's no waggery I only I
agree
no I agree I think we're just talking
okay crap okay all right all right so
you got Kate okay let's say it's the
next three years that'll make it more
interesting with LeBron so I'll take
LeBron with the second pick now who you
take it
Kawai Carly late OMPs over Kyrie and
curry yeah now I guess I probably should
have gotten to pick since I gave you the
first pick right yeah yeah all right I
thought you were going all right then
maybe I'll take two picks this time so I
got curry and Kyrie and then you got
Caleb or dream on Claire your graybar
but yo you want dream on so I got K love
and then your are you going to take
Tristan - who's who's that who's that
next guy you're taking um so you have
you have LeBron Curry Kyrie and Caleb
curry and Kyrie what second and third um
you and that UK love and threat
klay Thompson now I get to write you got
dream on and who all right now I get I
get one or two again you got one we only
go on top for there's only yeah sorry oh
you're I am going to Rick I'll give you
two shut up no we're building a five
okay you build a fire going on you get
to all right gives me crew bad um what
you left me
I love you the Frick we're yeah I guess
I'm going man Tristan and Iggy
Iguodala all right I'll take done I'll
take Shawn Livingston that's a good one
too
yeah if the Cavs have gotten swept do
you think that the offseason would be
different than if they I think I think
we just got out drafted by the way yeah
you did
I like my chances you're still better
looking Rick so if they had been swept
do you think we would have had a bigger
change bigger you know something a big
name would have been moved from
Cleveland and it still might happen uh
yeah yeah well you think a log I yeah
yeah cuz I got enough shooting and they
could pay interest and just hadn't been
rebounding but they could they could get
to put a two for one there for sure
Kevin let's play well don't take
anything away from Kevin I think I think
he's actually you know stepped up to to
the level of his stature on an NBA
Finals level and it play well play well
throughout these playoffs I don't see
him as solely responsible as we look
back to years ago when he was at his
best health-wise and they fell short
against the Warriors the first go-around
I think kevin has been better every year
he's been in the final so but he has
value not getting rid of Kyrie or LeBron
so Kevin Love would would bring in two
for one I think he's Rick Fox NBA TV
analyst joining us
which championship ring do you wear a
little more often or more proudly with
the Lakers um 2001 15 to 1 to our record
team that went undefeated on the road in
the playoffs that year that was that was
as strong a team mentally physically the
cohesiveness you know strength of
our two superstars were undeniable you
know they just the matchup nightmare
with Shaq and Kobe and I think the rest
of us were balanced in our understanding
of how to support them individually each
brought excellence in some area one or
two areas for the game so we just grew
rounded out in it to be a pretty darn
good team did Shaq run around naked all
the time like he did another NBA style
psychic did ever he liked to talk like
far more deep I should've but I I don't
we share these stories that he would
like running grab people and he'd be
naked yeah yeah no you look at that he
would do that there was a little you
never fully could relax a locker a shot
deal around goes that what I kind of you
know imma look out for him
really play games I give me your
favorite Jordan story that we haven't
heard wow I have a Jordan story it goes
back to to being high school college kid
working his camp and and staying uh
staying at the camp in between flying
back to Chapel Hill I got to spend the
night at his um at his house and hang
out with Michael Julian is a young kid
and I remember sleeping downstairs in
the basement of his house and and waking
up to him working out with his trainer
and and down in the basement and
watching him run on the treadmill I mean
the treadmill you know you go all out
right you put it on the fastest setting
and watching him run on the treadmill
for like might have been 30 minutes just
on full-blast speed and I never I never
thought treadmill a went that fast if
someone could stay on the treadmill for
that long and then I remember going to a
closet open up the closet and there were
the Jordans back then the Air Jordans
he was like magnets in 1989 when during
that he was starting to take off at his
stardom and he had at least
the 50 to 60 pairs of Jordans all just
in the closet that may have been worn
maybe once all different colors [ __ ]
yellow red blue didn't matter right
there's all these different colors yeah
and I look brand new but it was just you
could tell it maybe had him on for one
pair you didn't take anything I got to
pick a pair out of hair at one pair
Panda he's so quick have a pair I wish
I'd kept them Tuesday uh and then on the
way out a van from this soup company
that he used to used to I think be
sponsored by bugs bees i came rather
than the name of it or whatever pulled
up and literally the garage door open
and in came maybe fifty to sixty cents
and then I looked at the garage around
the garage in the garage might have been
60 pairs of golf clubs and I thought to
myself what it was the first thing I've
ever done in my mind was just blown
right by wouldn't let the beautiful
athlete or or is it granted I didn't
know it was extraordinary pairs of suits
and 60 pairs of golf clubs that your
closets just were filled with excess
shoes not the way it was things not not
the way it was for everybody
okay I'd like to have you on to talk
about your eSports team one of these
days Rick is the owner of eSports team
echo fox just signed a new league of
legends challenger team but I'd like to
talk to you about that when I have a
little more time Rick and I do a pre
talk you Julius definitely good talk my
buddy thank you that's a Rick Fox NBA TV
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience